All right, so I know that some people are
not going to like this segment and that's
okay
as long as we're able to have a productive
conversation about it. And I put aside the
time on today's show to actually be able to
do this. Um, we are about to head into an
election of extreme importance in so far as
the removal of Donald Trump. This is not just
politically based, but there are a number
of different just systemic weaknesses in our
democracy by virtue of having Donald Trump
in the oval office. We're looking now at a
delay of the census, which I'll talk about
on tomorrow's program. Relationships with
countries abroad. I mean this is way bigger
than Republicans and Democrats and more and
more Republicans by the way, are understanding
this when it comes to Donald Trump, we cannot
be distracted on the left by self-destructive
impulses. And last week I did live streams
of the d, the, the two debates, the one debate
that was split into two nights.
And after the second night a of debating ended
with the Democrats. I took some live calls
and I got a live call from a woman who wanted
to explain to me that there can be no such
thing as racism against white people and there
can be no such thing as racism by people of
color or minorities in the United States.
Now I got pretty agitated during the call
and now that a few days have gone by, I've
sort of reflected on why and realize that
it's not the disagreement in and of itself
that I found so disturbing and so agitating.
But it's that the conversation, uh, in and
of itself is one that when it becomes as toxic
as it did is the type of thing that can either
destroy the left or potentially seriously
hurt us. And I don't want to see that happen.
So I'm going to play the full clip for you
because I don't want to take any one piece
of it out of context.
This is the full conversation I had, uh, during
live calls after the debate last week, uh,
from a caller saying, white people can't be
the victims of racism. Uh, non white people
can't be racist in the United States. Take
a listen to this. Let's see who else we've
got here. Um, let's go to, oh, I don't know.
I mean, I'm just going, going crazy here with
area codes. Let's try it. Let's try the people
or something's up with the phone system. There's
almost like too many people holding. Let's
try the five, six one area code. Who's calling
today from five, six one? Hello. Yes, that's
you.
Am I alive? Oh God. David Packard. This is
great. Um, so basically, um, I have a question
really relating to the debate, but I want
to, I called the way before and it was, it
was, I think it was mentioned on your interview
with the Joe Rogan show and it was about that
tweet of that one woman who tried to get you
fired from Boston College because you tweeted,
doc, it's not progressive. Vote for someone
or not vote for someone based off of their
race, gender, whatever.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. I said that excluding candidates
merely because of their race or gender is
not so progressive. And she tried to get me
fired from Boston College for saying that.
Right. So what you said on the Joe Rogan show
in applied the, what she was saying was racist
and um, I called asking what you thought about
that because racism isn't a predicable to
white people. And I really wanted to hear
your thoughts from that because yeah.
Who says you can't be racist against white
people?
Well, okay. We have to really take a look
at what racism is because if we're going by
the definition that it's discriminating or
seeing a race as above or below another, that's
a very, a skewed definition where racism should
be examining the social, economic and political
system. And within this nation and other Anglo-Saxon
nations, there's only one group, the in group,
which are white people that have a political
socioeconomic power to oppress.
Nope, totally disagree with you. I think that's
a losing lesson. That's a losing redefinition
of racism. Um, uh, you can be, there's no
question that power dynamics are really important.
And thinking about whether racism translates
into structural oppression, but you can be
racist no matter what your race is. And no
matter what one other people's race is, uh,
I think it's extreme. What you're saying is
extremely problematic.
Well, why is my definition problematic when
it takes into account the historical, um,
implications of what white people as a group
have done to oppress people?
It's just not, it's just not the right, it's
just not accurate. You're, the first definition
you gave is the right one. And so I think
there's two things because it's not what racism,
you're just, you're coming up with a new definition.
It's like if I said, you know, I'm going to
read it. Hold on a sec. Well, you, you've
presented another definition, right?
And I think I'm presenting the most accurate
and holistic definition of racism.
And that's what, so for you, the most accurate
definition of racism is one in which no one
can be racist against white people. Is that
what you're saying?
That's, it's, uh, that's, I'm not saying that,
I'm not sure.
That's what you said. That's how you started
the conversation. You said you can't be racist
against white people in Anglo Saxon countries.
You can't be racist alleys in this nation
and this and this nation specifically because
that's what I studied with racism. This nation
specifically, you can't be racist to white
people because people of color don't have
the power.
Okay, hold on a second. Just hold, hold on
one second. Okay, let me, let me, let's just
take it. Let's, let's build it up. If a Hispanic
person says, I don't like white people because
they're white, is that racist? Okay.
No, it's not racist. However,
hold on a second. How was that not racing?
No, no. However, just how is it not racist?
It's not racist because the, okay, well I
can't, I can't say Hispanic because Hispanic
is an ethnicity, so I understand what you
mean by let's say person of color. A person
of color cannot be racist towards a white
person because they don't have the power.
Okay. All right, fine. So, so let let, we're
going through, just indulge me. If a, if a
person of color says, I don't like white people
because of their whiteness, that's not racist.
According to you. If they come, hold on. If
a company says, if a company says we are not
going to hire white people at this company,
is that racist?
Um, yeah. I, it's racially bigoted. It's racially
bigoted. Should we like
that slice of the left that you represent
is very small, but it is extremely problematic
and I completely disagree with it.
David, David, David, David, oh Mr Fine. How
have you, I want to address you. I follow
you because I think you're really reasonable.
Am I subscribed to you and I think it's great,
but yeah,
and what you're saying is extraordinarily
unreasonably trust in my reason. Then
how ever, however, what I'm saying is not
like some conspiracy theorists.
No, it's not concern. It's just wrong
idea. It's, it's not wrong because we have
people studying race and racism for decades
and anthropologists have come together to,
you're just wrong. Listen, hold on a second.
I'm, I'm a Hispanic immigrant to this country.
If I said I am going to Anakin it. Hold on
a second. Okay.
We're white.
If you really want to get down into ethnicity,
I'm actually Ashkenazi, but this is a whole,
this is why this is so stupid. If I say no
matter what my race is as if I'm white, if
I'm Hispanic, if I'm Ashkenazi, if I said
the David Pakman show is not going to hire
white people as a policy because I just don't
like having white people around that is racist
by any definition of the word. And any deviation
from that is completely counterproductive.
Okay? That's it's racially prejudice, but
racism needs to take the holistic definition
of prejudice plus power.
Listen, now you're just playing. Now you're
just playing semantic games. I'm going to
let you go cause the audience I think is tuning
out, but you're just wrong. I would urge you
to rethink your views and I hope that that
does not infect any of the Democratic candidates
dialog because that is self. This what you're
saying is a disaster. It's, it's, it's extraordinarily
damaging. Unfortunately, I don't think it's
super prevalent because what you're saying
doesn't make any sense. Um, okay. Well I mean
I'm shocked by that. I'm shocked by that.
So the mistake I made in this clip, aside
from just getting more agitated than I might
have wanted to, is that I actually completely
missed really getting into the big picture
of what's wrong here because yeah, I mean,
racism doesn't require systemic oppression
to be racism. I would have been better off
during the call distinguishing and saying,
I appreciate your perspective. I think we're
talking about the difference between racism
and systemic or structural oppression on the
basis of racist beliefs. Racism can exist
without using those racist beliefs to oppress
a particular group of people.
Uh, either way it's racism, right? Whether
it's racism plus oppression or racism without
oppression. Either way it's racism. But now
that I've actually had some more time to reflect
about the call, and I talked to a bunch of
people about it over the weekend. The real
problem here is that this type of argument
literally prevents actually talking about
solutions. What I mean by that is I've talked
about the narcissism of small differences
before. I've talked about the importance of
not missing the forest for the trees. When
we talk about politics and policy and what
we want to see, I believe that clearly people
of color can be racist. I believe that obviously
white people can be the victims of racism.
The requiring oppression to be racist makes
no sense to me in the same way that if you
have a KKK member in the middle of West Virginia
with racist beliefs, but no resources to actually
oppress anybody living in a rural place where
there isn't even anybody to oppress, that's
still a racist.
Right? Uh, in the same way a person of color
can be racist against white people, they may
or may not have the ability, resources where
with all their circumstances to oppress white
people because those people are white, but
they can still be racist. But here's the real
issue. This color, and I I would guess would
agree that in the United States, the issues
of racism, uh, have to be sort of, uh, understood
big picture. And that mostly issues of racism
in the United States are racism against people
of color, not racism against white people.
The color, and I, I I'm guessing would agree
that in the United States, historically most
racism but not all has been against people
of color and not by them. Uh, and it has been
by white people and not against them. That's
a historical reality. But look at how this
however long it was, six minutes a conversation,
we end up in an argument that's not only unwinnable,
she was totally set in this idea that white
people simply cannot be the victims of racism,
period.
Like at a, at a, uh, um, uh, a priori in an
a priori sense. It's an argument that we'll
never solve anything. Imagine that. I argued
with her for an additional hour and imagine
that she got me to agree. Okay. You know what?
You're right. You can't be racist against
white people. It would do nothing for the
majority of victims of racism in the United
States who are people of color in the United
States. This is completely self destructive.
It's energy and time that is being spent on
something that is not going to achieve change
for us. It is not going to put us in a better
position to put leaders in place that are
going to do good things rather than bad things
for us. So the argument about whether a person
of color can be racist, where are the lines
between ethnicities? I'm of Hispanic culture,
but a white person.
But at the same time I'm Ashkenazi, which
antisemites say are not actually white people,
but I still look white and speak without an
accent. And the which category. This is a
loser's argument. The argument, um, uh, does
nothing for us in trying to fix the issues
that we're facing in the United States. It
does nothing for us and trying to replace
Donald Trump with the most progressive possible
candidate, whoever we believe that to be.
And that's really why I was so frustrated.
Okay. Someone disagrees with me about the
definition of racism. Uh, I understand the
prejudice plus power definition of racism
has been around in academic settings and sociology
departments for awhile. It can be debated.
I mean, the color presented it as obviously
that's the right definition. Well, the idea
that you need prejudice plus power, uh, and
depression for something to qualify as racism
is not something that is unanimously agreed
upon, uh, there, uh, that that's, I don't
even want to get into that debate again because
I think that that is secondary or even tertiary
here.
The argument I had with the color does nothing
for me and I wish that I had instead said,
hey, you know what? I actually don't think
it matters how we each define racism. I think
you're obviously wrong by the way. Let's figure
out what policies we want in order to ease
the issues that are biased along racial lines
in the United States. My guesses, and I hope
I'm not, I mean I'm being charitable. I hope
I'm not being overly charitable. I know some
people will hear this and they'll say, David,
you, we're not going to have any sensible
conversation with that person. Uh, I think
maybe we could have, my guess is that mostly
our list of problems, uh, could be fixed and
policy prescriptions could be agreed upon
even if we couldn't agree as to the definition
of racism, which again, I totally agree with
that collar about.
So let me know what you think because my concern
is that is the type of argument which number
one is completely fruitless in terms of we
would, what we would gain from continuing
for an additional 16 minutes instead of just
six or a 60 minutes or 600 minutes. And if
the left gets pulled into that type of stuff,
it is going to take attention. It is going
to take resources and time is a resource and
other resources away from actually making
the decisions and becoming activists to really
affect change. And that is why I found it
so agitating and frustrating. I want to know
what you think. Okay. I'm on Twitter at d
pacman. The show is on Twitter at David Pakman
show. Was that a debate worth having or not?
How big a slice of the left do you believe
that ideology represents? And am I generally
right that it is a destructive, it is a distractive
and potentially self-destructive path for
the left to go down at a time where we are
approaching such an important election in
the United States of America. Let me know
Twitter at Deepak, the David Pakman show@davidpacman.com